on sait aussi que Alain Delon aime
beaucoup les chiens c'est lui qui a un
petit peu communiqué cette passion pour
les les
chiens vous l'avez reconnu c'est
Nathalie Delon 25 films une passion pour
le cinéma et une véritable fascination
pour les bergers
malinois lui c'est Massaï un malinois de
18 mois tout à la fois garde du corps
copain amis et peut-être encore un peu
plusz allez qu'est-ce qui vous a
intéressé en choisissant un chien
malinois j'étais assez contre les
malinois pour moi ils avaient l'air de
de bâtard de bargé allemand et c'est un
monsieur qui m'a fait découvrir cette
race et puis je suis allé chercher ce
Chen dans un élevage et si vous voulez
ce qui me plaît chez eux c'est qu'ils
ont un côté moins servil un petit peu
que les bergers allemands ils sont entre
le chat et le chien un petit peu et puis
ils sont beaucoup plus sauvages mais
sauvages comme un chat si vous voulez
pas sauvage comme un chien méchant ils
ont un côté vraiment faéin et puis alors
au point de vue de l'esthétisme enfin je
veux dire c'est un chi moi je trouve
beaucoup plus beau je veux dire c'est
l'intelligence vraiment je sais pas si
c'est parce que c'est une race qui est
plus pure que les autres parceil
comprend vite comme ça ah mais alors
comme ça il pige tout au quart de tour
mais il y a l'insttin terrible aussi
peut-être non bah il y a l'instin
l'intelligence je crois que ça compte
beaucoup quand même parce que tout j'ai
pas voulu le faire dresser si vous
voulez parce que ça m'intéresse pas dans
la mesure où il a suffisamment
d'instinct pour me servir justement à à
ce que je voulais je voulais un chien je
voulais un chien qui soit sociable tout
en étant au quart de tour si vous voulez
prêt à h pourquoi vous avez peur quelque
foois ouais je rentre je rentre souvent
seul bon je suis pas toujours
accompagnée social d'un garde du corps
mais c'est mon meilleur garde du corps
ça et alors le garde du corps je dire
moi j'ai pas tellement l'impression que
c'est le garde du corps parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il vous il vous
surveille puis vous le surveillez une
espèce de conivor Terri il y a a une
grande ce que j'aime avec ces chiens si
vous voulez c'est une énorme complicité
qui a qui a mais mais qui s'établit
toute seule justement parce que dès que
je l'ai pris pendant 6 mois j'ai vécu
avec ce chien je dire en conduisant ma
voiture dans ma parca ou dans mon bouson
ou n'importe où toujours là comme ça
tant qu'il était petit ce qui fait qu'
il croit toujours qu'il est tout petit
ce qui lui arrive souvent un grand bébé
ouais c'est un grand bébé mais je veux
dire j'ai jamais quitté ce chien si les
8 premiers mois il a été avec moi tout
le temps sans arrêt je lu fait à manger
je l'ai sorti le matin j'ai c'est c'est
un esclavage si vous voulez mais après
c'est fantastique on récolte les choses
fabuleuses ah mais c'est merveilleux je
veux dire il y a il y a une tendresse
une complicité qui n'existe pas de la
même façon avec les bergers allemands un
copain aussi ah c'est plus qu'un copain
je c'est la
tendresse si vous voulez c'est un chien
qui est qui est uniquement mais ça je
crois que c'est aussi je veux dire les
bergers allemands peu comme ça aussi
mais eux particulièrement sont attachés
à un maître à partir du moment où vous
allez chercher dans un chenil comme je
l'ai fait c'estd que je suis allé voir
une portée j'en ai choisi un et le
premier qui est venu vers moi c'était
lui c'est c'est lui qui vous a choisi il
m' peut-être choisi un peu oui il venit
faire des fêtes on aime toujours les
gens qui vous aiment
et et voilà parce que le berger allemand
c'est peut-être un chien plus plus lourd
moralement plus entier peut-être
mais un peu plus obtu pour moi si une
espèce de finesse aussi bien physique
que que moral je dire lui par exemple je
lui appris à marcher au pied ou je lui
ai appris à s'asseoir ou je lui ai
appris on sent dans dans la vie parce
qu'on vous a vu un petit peu vivre que
vous aimez les gens qui comprennent très
vite oui ça démarre très vite bon
comm moi vous m'avez dit on a j'ai eu
beaucoup de chiens et cetera on sait
aussi que alin Delon aime beaucoup les
chiens c'est lui qui vous a un petit peu
communiqué cette passion pour les les
chiens euh non non pas du tout je dire
alin c'est vrai qu'il aime beaucoup les
chiens et il a même un certain pouvoir
sur les chiens mais euh j'ai toujours
quand j'étais quand j'étais gamine
j'avais toujours des chiens mais si vous
voulez bon c'est lui effectivement qui
en dehors des chiens que j'ai eu quand
j'étais Maum dire c'est lui qui m'a
offert mon premier chien qui était un
dog allemand et euh et puis mon second
chien aussi qui était imp pergement mais
quand je l'ai connu il en avait 12 il a
un certain pouvoir qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par là il a pouir sur les
chiens bah alin a un pouvoir sur les
chiens qui fait que je suis très étonnée
par exemple mass qui est assez sauvage
quand il a vu al la première fois je
dira c'était une tendresse fol comme ça
alors est-ce que c'est l'instinct est-ce
qu'il sait que c'est parce qu'il sait
leur parler il a un regard par exemple
ah oui il a l'autorité il a la tendresse
il a il adore les chiens je dire bon
puain ça ça vous rend pas alors vous
avec le chat ça marche pas du tout le
chat c'est pas le chat ou j'ai peur je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai peur tu un peu
féine aussi
[Rires]
he alors par un chien sociable quand
même voyez oui justement parce que vous
faites un métier vous êtes sur des
plateaux vous tournez vous êtes une
actrice alors comment ça se passe au
début ça se passait très mal il mordit
un peu tout le monde vous avez des
anexote j'en ai oui j'en ai deux qui qui
sont passés avec le même acteur c'était
en Italie l'année dernière bon il y
avait par exemple une scène d'amour et
puis massaille bon était tout petit il
avait 6 mois et pas encore compris il
avait pas encore compris et j'ai eu une
scène d'amour et au moment où d'habitude
je lui dis ass si là il bouge pas et
puis on a eu cette scène d'amour il a
cru que la personne m'agressé il s'est
jeté sur lui et la deuxième fois alors
que ses chiens on les dresse si vous
voulez quand on veut dresser un chien on
les dresse par exemple pour justement
éviter qu'il ai peur d'une arme on les
dresse avec le bruit du revolver et
pendant la scène j'étais là en train de
de regarder la scène ou une scène de de
film dester et il s'est jeté carrément
sur sur la personne qui ten un revolver
dans sa main moi je m'y attendais pas
parce que j'avais dit ass là cétait ass
là je regardais la scène je pas il a
carrément mordu la vous tes une très
bonne actrice mais les contrats rqu
diminuer rapidement tant pis faire un
choix dans la vie oui Natalie alors
comment ça se passe avec les deux chiens
il y a de personalité complètement
différentetoi bah oui oui c'estàd
celui-ci et le chien si c'est pas
vraiment mon chien mais je l'ailevé
beaucoup parce que il appartient à
quelqu'un qui a vécu qui vit souvent
maison qui me laisse quand il s'en va et
cetera oui mon chéri ouis et puis qui a
sûrement une personnalité très
différente de la mienne cela dit je
crois qu'ils ont leur propre
personnalité je veux dire s le mass
c'est leadero c'est le leader c'est le
chef ah ben c'est oh non à sa manière
lui je dire avec le calme et non m pour
l'instant c'est bah c'est l'enfant
chérique de la maison dire c'est à moi
hein oui mais c'est bien ce que j'aime
bien chez eux moi ce côté ils sont ils
sont vraiment durs à privoiser si vous
voulez voilà je ve dire ce sont pas des
chiens qu'on peut
facilement mais ils sont très très très
c'est pasme facile c'est pas unomme
facile j'aime bien
ça si par exemple on vous disait
massille bon il est plus là et cetera si
vous aviez une autre R de chien à
choisir qu'est-ce que vous
choisiriez si massaille était plus là je
sais pas si j'en aurais un autre
vraiment ouais non mais c'est vrai je
veux dire j'ai j'ai j'ai beaucoup aimé
si vous voulez mes bergers allemands
j'avais avant particulièrement un chien
qu'on m'a tué qui s'appelait Charlie
mais bon benah il est mort j'ai eu
beaucoup de peine mais massille c'est
c'est quelque chose dans ma vie si vous
voulez qui est très très très important
bien sûr il y a y a mon fils qui passe
avant tout je dire mais massille je
crois qu'il passe après
[Musique]
Anthony